a former politician accused of killing a
journalist reaches out to 8 news now to
Proclaim his innocence we thank you for
joining us here at six o'clock I'm
Denise Valdez and I'm Brian Loftis
Robert tell us remaining in jail that's
where Aidan's now investigator Vanessa
Murphy interviewed him Vanessa's here
live in studio with the latest claims
from the accused killer Denise and Brian
Robert Tellis claims he was framed but
as we first reported police say they
have a DNA match as well as other
evidence tying him to the scene of the
murder
and you say that I'm innocent and that I
was framed charged with murder and
locked up for five months Robert Tellis
requesting an interview with eight news
now to give his side of the story did
you kill Jeff gearman
no I did not review journal
investigative reporter Jeff gearman
exposed issues in the public
administrator's office under the
leadership of Telus including a possible
affair with an employee telis then lost
the Democratic primary on September 3rd
gearman was stabbed to death outside his
home I don't have proof of who did it
but I know who gained
we are getting from framing me Telus
claims as the public administrator he
was working to expose a scam involving
Estates where individuals were moving in
fast to profit off property before
families of the deceased could the 8
news now investigators confirming
authorities are looking into the matter
but as far as the separate criminal case
against Telus police point to evidence
like telus's DNA under gearman's
fingernails how do you explain your
vehicle near his home how do you explain
the video of an individual who appears
to be you how do you explain the
clothing that was at your house how do
you explain the DNA as far as the
vehicle goes that
there's a vehicle that looks like mine
as far as any other evidence goes again
as far as what time it may have been
planted I couldn't say
you know again I know it's an incredible
story but that is the story it could
appear that you're you're grasping at
straws here because you know about the
evidence against you again if that's
what people want to
want to be the truth what would you say
to people who believe that you are a
narcissist who killed a journalist and
now you're coming up with another excuse
again you know at this point I'm coming
out with this the truth because
I've had to sit and wait for for some
time to to speak out
um just because my again Council had
advised that I shouldn't say anything
whatsoever
Telus and his attorney have parted ways
and he's looking for a new attorney he
says he wants his case to move through
Court faster a jury trial is set for
November Brian Vanessa the review
journal still working to prevent Metro
from searching Jeff gearman's materials
such as his cell phone that concern is
that it would potentially reveal sources
Denise